John stewart and his mission to satirize
the news was too successful.
Ultimately,
his work resulted in the proliferation
of the news comedy format Ad Nauseum,
a conglomerate that has become large
enough to resemble the thing they set
out to mock.
Let's start with news networks.
They too were victims of their own
success,
meaning that their success made them
betray their ideals.
News started out as a much humbler
servient profession.
Sure it was still a partisan,
but there's a whole lot less of it and
it carried some form of values including
truth,
independence,
fairness and impartiality.
But in the sixties,
this change news networks realized that
by getting advertisers involved,
you could make heaps of cash hand over
fist,
fist over Mike's,
and there's a lot of nuance that I have
to skate over here,
but in essence,
those values of journalism,
the reason most got into the game,
they're squeezed into 24 slash seven
news cycle.
This was one of John Stewart's main
premises in the daily show that the 24
hour news cycle is a system that is
antithetical to good honest journalism.
Media in general.
You said it yourself.
It is focused on conflict,
it's focused on creating drama and a
false sense of urgency for better or for
worse,
at 24 hour networks are now the leading
light of our information age of 24 hour
news networks are built for one thing
and that's nine slash 11.
In the absence of that,
they're not just going to say there's
not that much that's urgent or important
or conflicted happening today,
so we are going to gen up.
We are going to bring forth more
conflict and more sensationalism because
we want you to continue watching us 24
hours a day,
seven days a week,
even when the news doesn't necessarily
warrant that type of behavior,
and in this ecosystem,
stuart thrive precisely because he
wasn't a journalist.
He's there to throw popcorn at the TV.
He's there to mock sensational dialogue
and insincerity and the daily show finds
enormous success,
but Stewart made a mark beyond himself
in the wake of his success.
The daily show turned out,
satire host the way SNL turned out.
Comedians,
the daily show's original correspondence
now correspond almost completely to the
current comedy news programming.
John Oliver,
Samantha Bee,
Steven Cole,
bear,
Jordan Kepler,
there are a glut of these all daily show
apprentices and many of these have fun,
a lot of success,
which has had ripple effects across late
night who are scrambling to compete with
what is working.
Jimmy Kimmel has found his political
views,
of course,
and although he sounds very earnest,
isn't that good timing?
Jimmy Fallon tried it on.
Seth Meyers show has gotten political
and SNL has raised.
They're already politicized.
Show to a fever pitch of grandstanding.
The list could go on,
so let's summarize.
We've got a bunch of really successful
shows,
making money hand over fist that are all
competing for the same eyes,
rely on corrupt,
crazy,
sensational things to happen every day
to make into theater for their nightly
shows.
Lineup up all these shows and they start
to resemble something.
Something that would garner spit balls
from the back.
They all sound the same spoken like a
guy who's suspiciously worried that
racist presidents don't get statues
anymore.
Is Donald trump a racist?
I'll let you decide.
Yes.
For Yourself.
America might be white supremacists
show.
In my opinion,
this has everything to do with race.
It can be hypercritical of political
villains and apologists for political
allies.
Thank you,
Steven.
That's what I love about America.
You know,
it's the only place where a secretary of
state can be put on equal footing with a
screaming cantaloupe.
Okay,
fair enough.
Fair enough.
Are you concerned about the news that
Russians may have hacked our election?
No.
Hillary lies because she didn't campaign
in the swing states.
Moscow.
It's a red state.
I understand.
No,
They become defacto journalists serving
many Americans,
their news,
and they've become political actors.
Don't vote for Steven Harper.
Exactly.
Satire News became what they be held.
They overdramatize the absurdity of
politics to make headlines.
They pandered to a political party
instead of at least trying to be
centrist and during slow news days with
so many political comedy shows,
what can they do?
But to use stewards phrase,
we're going to gen up,
we're going to,
uh,
bring forth more conflict and more
sensationalism because we want you to
continue watching us 24 hours a day,
seven days a week,
even when the news doesn't necessarily
warrant that type of behavior.
All of the things that John Stewart sent
out to ridicule in news networks,
all our failings that his own proteges
have.
And that is the tragedy of Jon Stewart.
Yeah,
I think so.
If I'm wrong,
I'm joking.
Obviously.